how look at it we leave what we're doing
is I'm gonna get rid of this wrong graph
now is you treat these polygons as your
starting point so we're going to do this
in Reverse so because I haven't got one
of these ones drawn up I'm just going to
go off and this one and illustrate it
okay even though you already know what
all the numbers are you can see what the
process is okay there we go you've got
all of your um your cumulative frequency
in graphs there that's fantastic so well
we have this how do we go backwards this
is what you're being asked to construct
you can see for example on the right
hand side there this table is just an
example of one that course listed in the
first graph when you look at the next
graph see how these volume that these
values down the bottom they don't match
are so you want to pick your own values
okay so when I see this graph if this is
the one I saw I look at these and I see
okay I've got groups happening so that's
that's where I draw this okay no
interpretation really required okay now
then where do I go from there well I can
read these cumulative frequencies oh I
know I don't have a grid here but you've
got a grid on these right so you're
gonna look for the values that
correspond to the different classes
right so look can I say oh through my
excellent estimation skills I think
that's about three you know because I'm
just super accurate jewelry right and I
think this is about 21 like that okay so
I'm gonna fill out all of these okay now
once I do complete that Donna how do we
go backwards okay so before we add it so
this time I'm going to - right how many
people are in this top group it'll be a
hundred twenty minus 114 six how many
people are in this group
after 40 minus 114 you get the idea and
we're going to climb back up the ladder
I cannae go tada
that's it that was all you had to do so
you're gonna read it you're gonna look
for these values and then you're going
to do the cumulative frequency process
even reverse subtraction to get to there
does that make sense
all right excellent